so one of the many reasons that you can
travel to and explore in the newest God
of War is Muspelheim the realm of fire
many of you who are somewhat familiar of
Norse mythology or may have just seen
Thor Ragnarok will most likely expect
him to see the fire giant SERT or suita
as Muspelheim is said to be where he
patiently waits for Ragnarok for the
most part most baheim just serves as an
area where he can complete a series of
trials and slay one of the Valkyries but
you do eventually stumble across one of
the many yotan shrines this time devoted
to the fire giant we're at race and
Mamere explained that he was the first
of his kind who crafted the legendary
flaming sword and did battle with Thor
and Odin where and when these events
took place is not mentioned so who
exactly is cert what role did he play in
Norse mythology and will he feature in
the next game these are all questions
that we hope to answer by the end of the
video for those of you interested in
learning a bit more about how he
appeared in traditional Norse mythology
he was indeed the eldest of the fire
giants who lived in Muspelheim and his
name in Old Norse was thought to mean
black or scorched referring to him
appear in a slightly charred so it may
have resembled he's kin quite closely
but he was not like the other fire
joints for he was destined to bring the
end of the world come Ragnarok and to
aid him in this task he worked day and
night to construct a weapon like no one
had ever seen before a flaming sword
that was thought to be brighter than the
Sun and capable of engulfing anything it
touched in the flames of Muspelheim he
did not rest until his great sword of
fire was complete and it was this sword
that he would wield when he led the
Odin's across the Bifrost and into
Asgard where they would finally have
revenge for their brothers and sisters
slain all those years ago by Odin and
the other gods of the ICEA and venere
during this final battle so it would
slay the god Freya engulfed in the
Walden flame before it would eventually
sink into the sea so it is a figure that
can be closely linked to primordial
chaos in the same way that the North
Ward came to exist when the chaotic
fires of Muspelheim met with the
tranquil ice of nilton Heim we can
almost view syrtis symbolizing the fires
of Muspelheim once again disrupting the
balance of the cosmos and bringing
destruction before creation
many see the giant Emir has been the
first being to exist but the argument
can be made that cert came into
existence far before during the creation
of Muspelheim
Nutan I'm patiently waiting to fulfill
his destiny we can almost view cert as
the inevitable an unstoppable force of
change within the North's world now
despite not seen certain colorful
outside of his shrine in Muspelheim I
think we can safely assume that cert is
not amongst the Giants who was slain by
Odin and Thor and will certainly make an
appearance in the second or third
installment of the Norse franchise for
all we know cert is in fact in must
behind just hide in and waiting for agna
rock with Kratos making himself an enemy
of Odin and the icier we may very well
see him joining forces of certain the
other yo teens as they march on Asgard
during Ragnarok we may even see Kratos
wield inserts blade to help him destroy
the Norse pantheon quite similar to what
we saw him do with Blade of Olympus
previously cert is definitely an
interest in an iconic individual within
Norse mythology and I think the question
we should be pondering is when will he
make his appearance as opposed to will
we see him if you have any theories or
questions regarding cert and his
involvement in God of War or just Norse
mythology in general then let me know in
the comments below
you